pour le député socialiste julien dray la
démission de bernard attali d'air france
ne doit pas masquer la responsabilité du
gouvernement balladur qui a dit il
imposer au président d'air france un
plan social très dur parce qu'il était
pressé de préparer la privatisation de
la compagnie il y a quelques jours
encore le pdg d'air france pouvait se
prévaloir du soutien public d'edouard
balladur et de bernard bosson rappelle
signé soufi jouve avec la plus grande
discrétion
bernard attali quitte les commandes
d'air france un simple communiqué
annonce sa démission
quelques instants auparavant le ministre
des transports bernard bosson annoncé
l'abandon pur et simple du plan social
at elle dit il faut changer de plan
bâtir un autre autrement avec d'autres
méthodes et dans le dialogue dans
l'entreprise 12 octobre la colère qui
couvait depuis plusieurs semaines à air
france
éclate lors de la journée nationale
d'action cgt fo peu à peu le conflit
s'enlise dans les secteurs fret et
maintenance bernard at elle y reste
inflexible
fort du soutien du ministre des
transports nous allons maintenir ce plan
il est indispensable pour la survie de
l'entreprise
mais nous discutons avec les
organisations syndicales avec les
partenaires sociaux de l'entreprise
un chat nombre de mesures
d'accompagnement le plan est irrévocable
et il sera tenu est la direction qui a
ni avec nous au point ce plan a le
président d'air france est parfaitement
soutenu colin discordante dans ce front
uni
edouard balladur qui le même jour
appellent à plus de justice dans le plan
social j'ai demandé au ministre des
transports monsieur bernard bosson de
faire en sorte en liaison très étroite
avec le président et la direction de
l'entreprise que les discussions
reprennent
occupation des pistes affrontements avec
les crs
le conflit se durcit et puis vendredi
tout commence à se fissurer
le ministre des transports propose aux
syndicats d'aménager le plan mais la
base ne suit pas la semaine s'annonce
particulièrement difficile
le gouvernement a donc préféré calmer le
jeu et jouer les pilotes dans l'avion